in this lesson we're going to talk about
translating sentences into equations and
inequalities so this is an important
concept to understand for the s80 let's
go through some of the keywords that you
want to understand so first of all what
do you think when they say at most what
do you think that means do you think
that means equal to do you think it
means less than you think it means
greater than less than or equal to
greater than or equal to what do you
think that means when they say at most
well at most actually even though it
sounds like more like greater than atmos
means less than or equal to so you know
it's like if your parents say oh you can
watch at most one hour of TV a day can
you watch more no can you watch one hour
yes can you watch less than one hour
sure that most means you know up to but
not greater than so that most is that
much or less at least again students
people confuse me to see the word least
and they think were like less than you
know but it's let's say your parents say
you have to study at least two hours a
day you know that means you can study
two hours and equal to or greater than
right that much or more okay and then of
course product you know means time
quotient means divided differences
subtract some means add when you see of
course x that means you know x or
multiply these are important you know
keywords to understand when you're
translating from a sentence into an
equation or inequality let's go ahead
and try this example pause the video so
you can do it on your own will go
through it together three less than the
product of X n two is five what is the
difference of four times X and 12 ok so
pause the video see if you can do this
one on your own we'll go through it
together so here it says three less than
the product of X intuitional product
means multiply so action to multiply
together would be like two times X or x
times two now the mistake of students
oftentimes make it they do like a direct
translation they take each word to say
three they write the number three then
they say less than or less than you so
subtract that's minus but you want to
read the sentence version then kind of
go back and pick out you know the
important point so three less then the
product of X and two is five that means
three Lessing's we're taking three away
from 2x so don't get caught into the
trap where you're doing like
direct translation read it first then go
back and see if you can you don't make
sense out of it so product 2x3 less than
that we're taking away three is when you
see the word is that means equals five
okay right also by the way when you see
the word of all oftentimes means x okay
so it's like you know when you see like
of like twenty percent of this number
that means point 20 times that number so
others x is equals less than we're
taking away three so let's go ahead and
solve this equation by adding 3 to both
sides right so that gives us 2x equal 8
divide both sides by two okay x equals 4
okay so so far so good but then it says
what is the difference of 4 times X and
12 so the difference means subtracting
so the difference of 4 times X and 12 so
what I'm going to do now since we know
what X is I'm going to put four in place
of X so that's going to be 4 times 4
minus 12 let's 60 minus 12 which equals
four we've got it so this is a
multiple-step problem and that's
oftentimes what makes the you know the
standardized tests will bit more
challenging like the FCT you know
they're making you or forcing you to go
through multiple concepts in the same
problem so that they're testing you on a
few different things before you get to
your end result so again review these
terms if you need to I'll see you in the
next lesson